- [Instructor] The table below
shows the number of chickens
sold by four friends from January to March
except one entry is missing.
What number should go in the empty cell?
So let's see, this is the
empty cell right over here.
They haven't filled out how many,
let's see, this is chickens sold,
so we don't know how many
chickens Michael sold in March.
Well, we know how many he
sold in January and February
and we also know the total
he sold in the three months.
So he sold a combined four plus six,
he sold 10 in January and February.
He sold 10 in January and February
and we know he sold a total of 11.
So this 11 is really the sum
of these three right over here
so this right over here in
March has got to be one.
He has got to have sold one chicken
because we see four
plus six plus one is 11.
So let's check our answer.
There we go, let's try this one.
So here's the missing
cell and so once again,
we just need to look at the total.
The total is 107.
So these four numbers right
over here and one is missing
you need to add up to be 107
for the solar panel
installations in Wyoming.
So let's see, 32 plus 27 is 59.
59.
59 plus 26 is, let's see, 79, it is 85.
So these three add up to 85
but they're missing this
one right over here.
So this is going to have to
be whatever 107 is minus 85.
So that is 22.
22 solar panels in Q3
because if 22 is here,
22 plus this, this and this
should be equal to 107.
So we're missing how many
points Gabriela scores
in the first quarter right over here.
Once again, we know that she
scores 35 points in the game.
In the other three quarters,
she scores a combined,
let's see, 10 plus 10
plus eight is 28 points.
So if she's 28 in the other three quarters
and she gets to 35, 35 minus 28 is,
she must have scored seven
points in the first quarter.
Seven points.
Let's do one more.
So in Alabama, how many
solar panel installations
in the fourth quarter?
See, 33 plus 26 is 59 plus 21 is 80.
So to get from 80 to 101,
we need to get another 21
sold in the fourth quarter.
We got it right.